NFL analyst for Sports Illustrated mmm
QB comm came up with the top 400 players
in the NFL and Andy kind enough to join
us how did you come up with what was the
criteria for the rankings Andy yeah
that's such an inexact science so what I
did I basically started with is this
player a better than player B and if it
was too close to call then it became
well who has the more important job
who's like if the player a is a
quarterback and player B is a linebacker
player a is going to win out but I'll be
the first to say a list like this is
absolutely absolutely hot and inherently
flawed and it's an inexact science there
were some surprises there I guess the
biggest surprise where I had a problem
with the list is you did not factor in
injuries that here's Luke Kuechly coming
back JJ Watt coming back Gronk coming
back they ranked pretty high on this
list why not factor in the entry portion
of this yeah sure you know that's
something I struggle with all the things
I mean I watch film on every game and
you can see guys don't always look a
hundred percent you got a GU where do
you draw the line there the problem is
injuries impact guys in so many
different ways I mean Gronkowski has
been hurt every other year of his career
and once he's on the field he always
looks a hundred percent other guys get
on the field at 85 percent and they look
like they're 20% and there's nobody in
the NFL that knows this and has access
to this info and understands exactly
what a guy will be when he's hurt and
what everybody in the NFL also agrees is
that everybody's hurt at least a little
bit pretty much all the time so I guess
is just a way to eliminate as much air
as possible and you still leave some air
with injuries I tend to ignore them
unless they're absolutely glaring and
watt and very Kowski and Luke Kuechly
those guys they're scheduled to play
they're going to go over in Cal skis
full practice right now so I give them
the benefit of the doubt
we're also arguing this earlier what is
the most important position aside from
quarterback yeah it's a great discussion
I think most
it's going to depend on your scheme if
your a zone scheme defensively then the
answer becomes defensive and an edge
rusher if you're more of a blitz
oriented scheme where you design
pressure band those guys those teams
will not want a man-to-man cover corner
because you tend to play man coverage
behind most glitches and if you got guys
I can cover one-on-one you have a lot
more guys who can blitz and now you're
more flexible so that's probably most
people's answer I think they'd look on
that side of the ball because
quarterback is so important offensively
that if you have a great one that can
impact every other position I can make a
good receiver look great we've seen all
the time the Mannings and Bradys of the
world they make average offensive lines
look very good so it becomes on defense
and really the guys who can combat the
quarterback in it's an edge rusher or a
cornerback for most people yeah I would
look at Khalil Mac I mean if you're
looking at those edge rushers here Von
Miller bond Miller's probably to me
aside from all the quarterbacks would be
the second most valuable he doesn't miss
time due to injuries he's been suspended
but he almost single-handedly won a
Super Bowl for you he's a guy that you
always have to account for I would also
look at the offensive line collectively
with the Dallas Cowboys is maybe being
the second most important you know maybe
Smith their tackle tyronn Smith would be
the the other guy that I would put in
there any problems with those rankings
if I said those would be the two guys I
might have up there aside from a
quarterback no I have I would you would
get no rebuttal for me I think I had Von
Miller number four overall so you and I
see them very similarly and what makes
guys like Von Miller so disruptive is
that they forced you to change the way
you play offensively you have to adjust
your scheme for them so teams who play
von Miller and the Khalil max mean these
Hoover elite edge guys they have to do
stuff they're not accustomed to do and
they become less potent because if you
have add extra blockers you have to
throw the ball quicker change your
timing whatever it is those guys impact
games simply by being on the field and
then retirement Smith as far as he goes
he's probably the most athletic
offensive lineman I've ever seen
where does Cam Newton Rian Kaptur last
years MVP season or the year before MVP
season with last year's injury-plagued
season and substandard season
statistically I had I think I had him as
number 14 quarterback overall Cam Newton
to me is the most fascinating player
entering this season because what
Carolina their coaching staff has
basically said as we want to reprogram
Cam Newton and we want him to become fan
Roethlisberger and Roethlisberger was a
guy early in his career who went sandlot
mode a lot he took a lot of hits he was
a playmaker and latest career he's
become more of a Tom Brady type QB he
surveys at the line of scrimmage before
the snap the balls out very quickly it's
a quick timing offense they want Newton
to make the same transition they want
them to run less as well if they go
through with that and it looks like they
will they've drafted players accordingly
that is an unbelievably different type
of quarterbacking approach that's a huge
overhaul for a guy who was an MVP just
two years ago
so do we evaluate Cam Newton from 2015
we have to factor in the ups and downs
of 2016 he's always been a mechanically
inconsistent passer which I think is why
he'll struggle and a quick strike scheme
and then or do we look at him as Cam
Newton 2017 he'll be a quarterback who's
being asked to do stuff he's never been
asked to do he's going to be getting the
ball out a lot quicker they have been a
deep drop back passing theme for his
entire career he's gotten better pretty
much every year to a certain degree
within that scheme so I don't know what
Cam Newton is right now because
supposedly they're going to ask him to
be something that he has not been yet
man and there's so much riding on this
that you're changing your offense you
drafted running backs who can be wide
receivers out of the backfield you know
you're not going from the home run and
and these design runs that they had on
Carolina that you know are they going to
you're taking away one of your weapon
you know one of his weapons to try to
preserve him but are you doing a
disservice to you know how he's going to
be able to play now he's going to be
thinking you know when I bring it down
and run no no Brady wouldn't do that Ben
we
do that like that that's going to play
games with Cam Newton's mind this year I
agree with you and the other thing to
remember Cam Newton is a tremendous
power thrower but when you run a quick
strike offense you're a precision timing
thrower that's totally different and
Newton is not good in those capacities
and I know that I've talked to NFL
coaches around the league and we've
talked about this change that Carolina
is making and the teams that have played
against Newton have said we are praying
they go through with this development we
would love to see Carolina
Annamayya meet the precision timing
thrower and they'd absolutely love to
see him eliminated from the run game
because with Newton now when why he's so
valuable as is he's a running threat by
design he's not a scrambler yeah it's
not scramble he barely does that he runs
by design and that totally changes the
math of the run game at now it changes
the body count for the defense in the
box and because of that it changes the
angles that you can get to all of your
blocks on those defenders it deemed
teams are not prepared they're not set
up to defend running quarterback in the
NFL so it's a tremendous advantage just
the threat of Newton running so for
Carolina to be talking publicly about
how we're not going to run them anymore
if they come out of weeks one and two
and they go through with that and they
don't run with him not only will they
lose the running plays with Newton but
they'll lose the advantage of teams
having to account for Newton in the run
game going to make it harder on their
running backs did Kaepernick make here
top 400 list no I'm not a Kaepernick guy
it's nothing personal I I kind of admire
what he does personally in fact but from
a football standpoint I am NOT in the
Kaepernick camp you don't buy any of
those numbers quarterback rating over 90
what was he 19 touchdowns four
interceptions last year of those those
are hollow numbers to you well yeah a
little bit because what and there were
times look he played great for certain
stretches I remember the Miami game and
parts of the Arizona game he was as good
as any QB in the league for stretches
there he's unconventional he's not a
traditional drop back pocket passer and
what can never be captured statistically
and it is an enormous part a quarterback
you probably
second biggest problem a QB can have
beside turning the ball over our throws
that are supposed to be attempted that
or not because the quarterback didn't
see it
he wasn't on time he wasn't prepared to
throw from the pocket because his
mechanics are broken down whatever it is
and when you put on the Kaepernick film
and you watch it from the overhead every
week you see that on a regular basis you
see it to the extent that it starts to
impact the play calling and now we're
talking about a much much more limited
offense and that's why coaches are
having trouble wanting to bring him in
because they see a guy that's going to
have you're going to have to reduce your
offense to account for him and then the
fact that it's not a pocket passer means
you're going to have to redesign a lot
of your offense and that's that's just
not realistic to expect the team to
invest in a backup quarterback under
those conditions great stuff and Eastern
it up with your list on the nmq be calm
have a good weekend we appreciate you
joining us I think Stan appreciate it
all right the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience